just looking at the explicit debts the
figures are staggering Global total
private and public sector debt as a
share of GDP Rose this is insane Tom
from 200 in 1999 to 350 in 2021 the
ratio is now
420 across advanced economies and 330 in
China in the United States it is 420
Which is higher than during the Great
Depression I have to read this to you
one more time I don't know if you kind
of were distracted put your phone aside
and just listen to this for a second I'm
I'm asking you to listen to this for a
second I'ma read the sentence just
looking at explicit debts how much debt
we have the figures are staggering
globally total private sector and public
sector debt as a share of GDP Rose from
200 in 1999 to 350 in 2021 the ratio
today is 420 across advanced economies
that's 330 in China but U.S is at 420
Which is higher than during the Great
Depression and after World War II damn
of course that can boost economic
activity if borrowers invest in New
Capital Machinery homes public
infrastructure that deals returns higher
than the cost of borrowing but much
borrowing goes simply to finance
consumption spending up above one's
income on a persistent basis and that is
a recipe of bankruptcy more of
investment in capital can also be risky
whether the borrowers or household
buying a home at an artificially
inflated price a corporation seeking to
expand too quickly regardless of returns
or government that is spending the money
on white elephants extravagant but
useless infrastructure projects hence
the buildback better or other items that
they're doing the inflation reduction
whatever it was called the reduction and
react with governments unwilling to
raise taxes or cut spending to reduce
their deficits Central Bank deficit
monetization will once again be seen as
the path of least resistance but you
cannot fool all the people all the time
okay when you hear this here this guy's
saying this Tom first thing you're
thinking about is what what I'm thinking
about is so put it in perspective
420 percent that means we owe ourselves
four times our annual pay if you want to
think of it that way as a nation and as
interest rates go up we got to pay the
the interest on that which is what makes
that debt be a bigger and bigger percent
of what we have to pay every year and
there's less for positive programs and
like Highway infrastructure so that
Rusty bridges in Wisconsin don't
collapse remember that and those people
ended up in the in the river so
basically you know if we think personal
debt is bad that's nothing compared to
all of us
can we just give a shout out to uh the
writer of this article yeah Tyler Durden
from Fight Club is the author of this
article writing now this is Zero Hedge
and he uses I know zero he uses the
Tyler yes of course but you know this
Tyler Durden destructive doomsday or we
all know that but you know I asked you a
question earlier Tom about like the the
reasons why we think the housing market
would crash and you know the the
correlation with what happened in 2008
but for years and years and years we've
been we've been hearing about this
potential debt crisis and this obsession
with debt whether it's in personal debt
whether it's business debt whether it's
gdps countries borrowing debt African
nations going into debt to China debt
debt debt debt Iran borrowed how much
money from China
but this obsession with debt it's not
going to have a good ending for a lot of
people I mean I'll tap into my inner
Dave Ramsey here but Dad is dumb and
unless you can kind of you know what
they what they highlight here unless you
can kind of borrow money and then parlay
that into a higher rate of return yeah
you can obviously grow your wealth and
grow your country's GDP but the downside
to it which is article highlights it
could get very very ugly and middle what
Pat red it says but borrowing that goes
simply to finance consumption or you
mean like 1 4 1.4 trillion dollars that
was just handed to people that went to
Vegas and bought things yeah yep so
exactly anyways so so all in all Vinnie
in other words you know the economy is
still got some work to do until it
recovers back to normalcy that's not
going to happen for a minute so what all
the craziness taking place I believe
future looks bright if you believe
future looks bright get your latest
Future looks bright hat of valuetainment
it says future looks bright here future
looks bright here we got them in white
we got them in Black we got them in red
our black on black sold out these are
about to sell out if you haven't ordered
one yet we had a person in Michigan but
one then he bought three then when those
three people wore it in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
want it the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody's saying future
looks spread toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
[Music]